hello and welcome to 3abn today Bible q
a I'm Jason Bradley and I'm so glad that
you are searching God's word for those
hidden gems he wants to reveal them to
you and you are searching for answers
from his word so I want to thank you for
submitting your questions if you haven't
submitted your questions I want to share
with you how you may do so you can text
us at
618-228-3975 again that number is
618-228-3975 or you can email us at
bibleqa at
3abn.tv bible QA at
3abn.tv and if you're on Instagram you
can always send us a DM that's a direct
message at 3abn underscore official
again that's 3abn underscore official we
have some wonderful students of the word
that will be answering the questions
that have been submitted and I will
introduce them in just one moment but
I'm want to share a scripture with you
it's taken from Proverbs chapter 3
verses 1 and 2. my son do not forget my
law but let your heart keep my commands
for length of days and long life and
peace they will add to you here with us
tonight to study this word the wonderful
word of God we have Shelley Quinn it's
great to have you it is lovely to be
here yes what do you enjoy about
studying God's word everything you know
if I've had a really busy day or a busy
week or or if you really haven't been in
the word for 24 hours I can open up the
word of God and it's just like
you're breathing in fresh air I love it
amen amen and sitting next to you we
have Pastor John dinzi it's great to
have you here it's a blessing to be here
you know God's word is a treasure of
knowledge and wisdom able to lead us in
the knowledge of Salvation amen amen and
right next to you we have an another
John Pastor John Lowe McCain it's great
to have you here on Columbia always good
to be here you know we have that term of
endearment nephew that's right somebody
once asked is he really your nephew said
in Jesus he is that's right but we
appreciating God what he does when his
word is opened we're reminded that it's
not a book that can easily be entered
into we got to get our deep sea diving
equipment on because God's word is
inexhaustible amen amen and it's such a
challenge because you only have three
minutes to answer these questions and
you get four minutes for one of your
questions and that can be challenging
with some of the questions that's that's
submitted will you pray for us to start
loving Lord we thank you for your word
it's a lamp it's a light it's a path it
is a book that continues to breathe
breathe forth the words of life
father you said to us let this mind be
in you which is also in Christ Jesus as
we imbibe the word we pray that the word
imbibes us that we don't look for the
truth but we thank you that we stop
running from the truth that has been
running after us we don't have the truth
we thank you Lord that the truth has us
so guide our minds today as we answer
these questions but may all the glory
and the honor go only to you in Jesus
name we pray
amen Shelly we're going to come to you
for this first one this is actually your
four minute question
how do I explain the godhead to a friend
who cannot grasp the concept of the
three being one this is from Nicole out
of Trinidad Oh Nicole what a question
for four minutes uh the word used in the
New Testament to describe God's divine
nature is godhead and this reveals three
distinct persons in one there's God one
God the Father Son and Holy Spirit there
are 58 passages that refer to these
three but we know that they share the
same essential qualities the nature and
their purpose and plan Jesus said in
Mark 12 29-30 the first of all the
Commandments is this hero Israel the
Lord Is Our God the Lord is one and you
shall love the Lord your God with all of
your heart with all of your soul with
all of your mind and with all of your
strength this is the first commandment
so Christians believe in one God he's
quoting from Deuteronomy 6 4 here and in
the Hebrew the word for one is and that
can indicate a compound Unity now
apost the Apostle Paul clearly describes
plural persons of the godhead saying
there's one Spirit one Lord one father
but these three live in perfect Unity
and divine humility they these three
persons don't seek Superior Authority
within their Circle of Love so here's
the bottom line how I explain it
we get confused because you think oh
well if there's the father Son and Holy
Spirit one plus one plus one is three
Gods we're using the wrong mathematical
formula in the Bible there's two places
that represent the presence of God the
most holy place in the temple and the
New Jerusalem and guess what they're
with their length and their Dimension
are all the same that makes them cubes
God's presence is in the cube so how do
you calculate a cube you multiply a
number three instances of the same
number by itself that's a cube so the
dimensions of God's
nature are equal they're interchangeable
three persons of the same value
one times one times one equals one
that's right one to the third power one
cubed so God in the nature of God is one
to the third power and that makes
perfect sense can you think something
else in the Bible where someone perhaps
where God uses multiplication to explain
more than one person is one yes he said
when a husband and a wife are joined
together
they become one one times one is one so
this is the only way that I can think of
to respond to the question how do we
explain the Trinity it is a mystery but
it is very clear in Scripture that God
the father
Son and the Holy Spirit are all one amen
you know I'm so glad that you got that
question I was recently witnessing to
someone who doesn't believe in the
Trinity so I'm going to refer them to
this program yes they did yes Pastor
dinzi God has been convicting me to do
something but I'm not really willing to
do it I am reluctant is it okay for me
to ask God to give me a willing heart
and to make me want to do what he asks
this was sent via email
that is a wonderful
question because of what it seems to
imply and I want to say absolutely yes
you can ask him to give you a willing
heart and I would like to bring to you
Philippians chapter 2 verses 12 and 13.
therefore my beloved as you have always
obeyed not in my presence only but now
much more in my absence work out your
own salvation with fear and trembling
now notice for it is God who works in
you
both to Will and to do for his good
pleasure and you can give him your will
you can consent for God to take your
will and this is something that is uh
very interesting because you say God is
convicting me you're acknowledging that
the holy spirit is working in your heart
to help you make this decision but you
must make the decision and it says you
are reluctant it's like there's this
struggle within you and this is the uh
something that you can look back and say
you know it is good because if you're
talking about a moment before you're
converted it's like you're just
following whatever the Flesh and the
mind bring to you but there's this
struggle going on so I encourage you to
surrender to the Lord allow him to lead
you because if God is convicting you to
do something that means it's for your
benefit in Isaiah chapter 48 verse 17
and 18 it says thus says the Lord your
Redeemer the Holy One of Israel I am the
Lord your God who teaches you to profit
who leads you by the way you should go
all that you had heed at my Commandments
then your peace would have been like a
river and your righteousness like the
waves of the sea so God wants to give
you peace he wants to give you Victory
and he's convicting you to do something
now I'm not sure what that is we don't
have any information on that but if God
is leading you to give up a sin then do
it immediately because you will be all
the better for it if God is leading you
to accept a Doctrine and you're
reluctant to do it then uh you are
fighting against the Holy Spirit and
that can be dangerous so yes go to the
Lord in prayer and say Lord I surrender
all I want to be in harmony with your
will help me to understand what you want
me to do how I can cooperate with you
because if you want to be in harmony
with the Lord then that is the best
course of action so please yes go to the
Lord and say I am willing Lord and you
know you can look at Jesus there in the
Garden of Gethsemane and then this was a
huge huge test and he said take this cup
for me never that nevertheless not as I
will but as you will place yourself in
the hands of the Lord amen amen
beautifully said you know there's
there's nothing better than walking in
God's purpose and plan for for your life
that's right you can't you can't lose
you can't lose you might have to step
outside your comfort zone for a second
but um but you will get comfortable in
What the Lord Has for you that's right
for sure Pastor Loma King what makes the
Christian faith any more credible than
the others this is from Jacoby out of
Oklahoma uh thank you Jacoby for that
question credibility is a very important
question because without credibility
then authenticity is also lacking you
find that the Christian faith if you say
then all the others and I'm assuming you
mean all the other movements in the
world they may be Buddhism or Islam or
whatever it is New Age whatever the
Avenues are that people may practice
their religion
what makes the difference is
Christianity first and foremost is based
on the person of Jesus Christ you know
there is no place where his body is
contained when we were in the Bible
lands we went to one of the places of
the five that they thought Jesus
possibly was buried here but the curator
of the of the Tomb area said well the
good news is there are five places in
this vicinity where we think Jesus could
have been buried but the good news is
he's probably in the sixth one and there
is none and he said but the good news is
he's not in any one of them see
Christianity boasts the fact that his
founder is not dead He's Alive
forevermore that's the first thing
second thing is when you have faith in
Christ it's not faith in faith it's
faith faith in Christ it's not a blind
faith it's the kind of Faith that's born
when you receive him as the Bible says
in John 1 verse 12 but as many
as received him to them he gave the
right to become children of God to those
who believe in his name Faith causes you
to believe not in something as much as
it causes you to believe in someone so
we base our faith not on just the fact
that the Bible says it and I believe it
but Jesus is an undeniable fact in
history people may say he's a prophet
he's a good man he's a teacher but it's
an undeniable fact even atheists believe
that Jesus exists why would they fight
against somebody who they don't believe
exists why spend countless Millions
trying to disprove his existence is like
me spending billions of dollars trying
to prove that there are no six dollar
bills doesn't make any sense I have to
believe that it exists to try to prevent
you from believing it the other thing is
the faith that we find in Christ changes
us Second Corinthians 5 17 therefore if
anyone is in Christ he is a new creation
all things have passed away behold all
things have become new many of the
movements of religion don't claim
newness in the fact that we are
transformed from Death To Life
and it causes a person to be more
involved in the works that may
eventually save them like pilgrimages
and climbing the steps and beating
oneself or doing all kinds of unusual
worths worthless Works whereas
Christianity
our salvation is based on great grace
through faith in Christ alone not of
works less any Manchester both so in a
nutshell I would say our faith comes by
hearing hearing by the word of God we
are born of God we overcome the world
through the blood of Jesus Christ and
the works that we do are just the
evidence of our faith and unshakable
faith in the person of Christ amen amen
amen if we were saved by works we'd be
in trouble we would be in trouble a lot
of people posting oh yeah
Shelly yes I believe Jesus Is God God is
our heavenly father the creator of
everything under the sun however there
has been a dangling question on my mind
for some time who is he speaking to when
he's on the cross
father why hath Thou forsaken me this is
from Annette out of New Zealand and it
praise God that you recognized that
Jesus is God many people don't and I
want to set that up first in Philippians
2 5 3 8 the Bible says have this
attitude in yourselves which was also in
Christ Jesus who although he existed in
the form of God before from eternity
past he did not regard equality with God
a thing to be grasped and held onto but
he emptied himself and took the form of
a bond server being made in the likeness
of man being found in the appearances of
man he humbled himself by becoming
obedient to the point of death even
death on a cross
our Creator God
came down from heaven to take on our
flesh that's
such humility it's hard for us to
believe but John 1 1-3 tells us in the
beginning was the word the word was with
God the Word
was God and all things were made through
him without him nothing was made that
was made and then verse 14 says and the
word god became flesh that's right and
dwelt among us to think our God would
step the Lord Of Glory would step out of
heaven and take on this human flesh
forever because he also acts 1 tells us
he returned to heaven in the flesh as
the last Adam it's glorified flesh but
it was flesh so the rulers didn't
recognize who he was and I love how Paul
speaks of this mystery in First
Corinthians 2 7-8 he says we speak the
wisdom of God in a mystery the hidden
wisdom which God ordained before the
ages for our Glory
for God ever created the world
Revelation 13 8 says that Jesus was the
lamb slain from the foundation of the
earth God knew we could not restore our
righteousness through works it had to be
by faith but he says which none of the
the rulers of this age knew for had they
known they would not have crucified the
Lord Of Glory Colossians 2 9 says in
Jesus dwells all the fullness of the
godhead bodily as I mentioned a while
ago there are 58 passages Annette that
referred to God as the Father the Son
and the Holy Spirit one times one times
one equals one and once the only number
that can be divided by itself and still
equal one that's why in Jesus was still
the fullness of the godhead in John 10
30 he said I and my father are one he
claimed equality so on the cross you
have who we call the second person of
the godhead not second in Authority or
power but second in his full exposure if
you will the second person of the
godhead is on the cross he's speaking to
the first person of the godhead
Jesus became the Covenant Son of God and
this first person considered himself
father so that is who he's speaking to
great explanation thank you thank you
great breakdown Pastor dinzi how do I
abstain from fleshly lust so that I can
receive the Holy Spirit Jesus said if we
follow his commands he will send us a
helper which is the spirit I really want
the spirit to intercede for me and
dictate the pace of my life but my weak
flesh makes me fail to follow the
commands of Jesus apart from Earnest
prayer what other steps can I take that
will assure me that I will overcome the
fleshly lust this is from Raymond
amen for your question another wonderful
question Raymond I I appreciate your
concern and
it's under we have we should understand
that we are weak
but understand that God is strong and
that with Jesus all things are possible
and so what else can you do you say
there are things that we can do I like
to start in Isaiah chapter 1 verse 16
and 17. notice how it says here because
there's a part in US cooperating with
the Lord it says wash yourselves make
yourselves clean can you really do that
without the Lord no it says put away the
evil of your doings from before my eyes
cease to do evil can we do that without
the Lord's help no so prayer is a part
of it but then making decisions
according to the way the Lord leads you
and following through because you can
say all day long I am going to give up
smoking I am going to give up smoking
but your will your decision must be
followed by a corresponding action and
so it says in verse 17 learn to do good
seek Justice rebuke the oppressor defend
the fatherless plead for the Widow so
doing good things connects you with the
Lord and and helps you maintain the
focus Jesus gave us the example that we
see in Psalm 119 verse 11. it says your
word have I hid in my heart that I might
not sin against you so besides prayer
there is the study of God's word that
will be of great help not only notice
that it says hidden in my heart that
means committed to memory and not just
to repeat it as if you're repeating the
a b c d e f g is you're committing it to
memory so that you can ask the Lord
teach me what this verse really means
and when you review it you can keep
asking the Lord help me to understand
that God so loved the world that he gave
his only begotten son you can ask the
Lord to help you understand Matthew
chapter 11. notice the words of Jesus
come to me all you who labor and are
heavy Bladen and I will give you rest
are you struggling with the fleshly Lost
Jesus can give you rest from that he
says take my yoke upon you and learn
from me study the Life of Christ how he
handled himself facing criticism facing
challenges from the scribes and
Pharisees and Sadducees and look at the
way he handled himself why because
there's this law that we're going to
read in second Corinthians 3 18 that I
need to go quickly here take my yoke
upon you and learn from me for I am
gentle and lowly in heart and you will
find rest for your souls for my yoke is
easy and my burden is like what Jesus is
asking us to do is to trust in him
because with him all things are possible
Second Corinthians 3 18 but we all with
unveiled face beholding Us in the mirror
the glory of the Lord are being
transformed into the same image from
glory to glory that is from character to
character just as by the spirit of the
Lord the only way that we can be
victorious is by allowing Jesus to live
in US and that's how we can cooperate
with him amen that total surrender total
surrender amen Pastor Wilma King
scripture says we should not mess with
the spiritual world I also know from
scripture that demons can impersonate
loved ones who have passed away I have
had visual auditory and olfactory
experiences which have been of loved
ones the experiences are reassuring and
I have felt the joy to have that
connection but I am wary of evil spirits
manipulating our emotions to their
advantage however in scripture Spirits
visited biblical figures and they were
sent by God could it not be that God
would have sent Angels or angels in the
form of my loved ones to comfort me this
is from Lynn out of New Zealand well
thank you for that question Lynn I'm
going to clarify something right away
that was a long question but the answers
that I believe are going to clarify what
your question is are found in God's word
one thing I want to bring out really
quickly uh when the Bible talks about
spirits coming to people that talked
about ministering Spirits God never
sends spirits of dead loved ones to talk
to anybody among the land of the living
you may be referring Loosely to the
story of The Witch of Endor and Saul uh
where he didn't see the spirit he asked
the witch what did she see and she he
said she perceived that it was Samuel
but the devil has that ability the Bible
refers to them as familiar spirits so we
find in the book of Hebrews let's start
with ministering Spirits because you
made that connection and you also
pointed out that in your experiences
that you it brings you comfort well the
danger of comfort is Comfort lessens
your your cautions it lowers your guards
and it leads you to the place where
seduction is getting more and more easy
and that's why you have to be very
careful I had a young man that contacted
me in Florida a young man who said his
mother visited him but he was nervous
and I said the reason why you were
nervous is because you sense the evil
presence even though they look like your
mom and I told them what to do and it
never happened again so the devil does
not play fair he works on seduction and
he starts by deception and what most
non-threatening way to come to me then
in the form of somebody that I knew but
let's talk about the real ministering
Spirits Hebrews 1 verse 13 but to which
of the Angels said he at any time sit on
my right hand until I make thine enemies
thy footstool Hebrews 1 verse 14 speaks
about these Spirits these angels are
they not all ministering Spirits sent
forth to minister for them who shall be
Heirs of salvation
the Bible refers to angels in that
context but angels will never come in
the form of a dead loved one the Bible
tells us why in first Timothy 4 verse 1
now the spirit expressly says that in a
lot of times some will depart from the
faith giving heed to seducing spirits
and doctrines of devils or deceiving
spirits and doctrines of demons the
Devil comes in the form of a spirit and
he does it in a way that will say hmm
and as a child I saw a Casper the
Friendly Ghost well I Saw The Ghost and
Mrs Muir so the Halloween I mean are
their Spirits floating around the world
I mean I've heard about them growing up
but this is a good one I've had a person
once a family said to me we have a good
spirit that visits us I said there are
no such thing as good spirits here's
what the Bible says about these
deceiving Spirits Leviticus chapter 20
verse 27. a man or a woman who is a
medium nowadays we call them seances who
has familiar spirits shall surely be put
to death they shall Stone them with
stones their blood shall be upon them
God specifically warned them do not be
involved in familiar spirits why because
Ecclesiastes 9 verse 5 says the living
know that they will die but the dead
know not anything when they die their
love their hatred their envy perishes
and Nevermore will they have a portion
and anything done under the Sun so it's
not your family coming back to make you
wow that's uncle's cologne oh that's how
he speaks oh that's how he sounds or
that's the number on the back of his
jersey the devil is very very clever
but in Isaiah 8 20 we said to the law
and to the testimony if they speak not
according to this word it's because
there's no light in them it's preceded
by Isaiah 8 19 and notice what it says
and when they say to you seek those who
are mediums and wizards who whisper and
mutter these are people that claim today
they could contact the dead should not a
people seek their God Amen should they
seek the dead on behalf of the living
the answer is no because the dead know
not anything and job says it in job 7
verse 9 to 10 as the cloud disappears
and vanishes away so he who goes down to
the Grave does not come up he shall
never return to his house nor shall his
place know him anymore so if you're
seeing spirits it's not your uncle amen
amen you know the world is being swept
up by that stuff but you just provided
ample proof from the word of God right
yes and perhaps you've heard something
here today so far then you're like man
that Sparks another question in my mind
I really want to send it in let me share
with you how you can do that you can
text us at
618-228-3975 again that's
618-228-3975 or you can send us an email
at bibleqa at
3abn.tv again that's Bible QA at 3abn.tv
and if you're on Instagram please send
us a direct message at 3abn underscore
official again that's three a b n
underscore official Shelley
I am confused about the feasts after I
read this in Ellen G white's Acts of the
Apostles page 390 paragraph four it says
Paul Terry to keep the Passover Paul is
New Testament so if we are not supposed
to keep the feast why does this say that
Paul did this is from Sherry okay let's
Sherry thank you for this wonderful
question and I'm going to start off
explaining why we don't keep the feast
when God during The Exodus has God
brought the Hebrews out of Egypt took
him three months to get to Mount Sinai
once they finally arrived at Mount Sinai
what did God do he spoke The Ten
Commandments these are Commandments that
Abraham Isaac and Jacob were familiar
with and we find them all in Genesis he
spoke them to the whole assembly of the
people to remind them of his moral code
of love now he calls Moses on up the
mountain and he gives to Moses civil
social and moral laws that are going to
be the legislation the constitution for
the new nation of Israel we find those
in Exodus 20 22 through Exodus 23 and
verse 33. so these ceremonial laws
included annual feast and annual
sabbaths that pointed to the ministry of
the Messiah the old this is it says in
Exodus 24 7 and 8 Moses wrote these
words in the book of the Covenant he
ratified in Exodus 24 he ratifies this
old Covenant the Civil social and moral
laws built around the Ten Commandments
we're at the heart of it but he ratifies
this old Covenant of several laws and
Feasts which were symbolic of Christ
Paul calls that the tutor in Galatians 3
26 he says this is the tutor that is to
bring that was meant to bring them to
Christ
Hebrews chapter 10 and verse 1 talks
about these ceremonial laws saying that
they were a shadow of the good things to
come and not the very image of
the things Jesus was the body that cast
The Shadow
so in Ephesians 2 15.
it Paul writes Christ abolished in his
flesh the enmity that is the law of
Commandments contained in ordinances so
as to create in himself one new man from
the two thus Making Peace so all of
these laws the constitution of Israel
Christ abolished so that Jew and Gentile
are one now listen to what Paul says in
First Corinthians 9 19-23
for though I am free from all men
I have made myself a servant to all that
I might win the more and to the Jews I
became as a Jew that I might win Jews
verse 22. to the week I became as weak
that I might win the week I have become
all things to all men that I might by
all means save some I do this for the
gospel's sake so Paul was willing to
comply with habits and customs and
opinions as others as long as he did not
have to compromise the principle and he
observed the Passover so that he could
witness to the Jews but he didn't do it
as a work of Salvation people today we
can do that but Paul wrote In First
Corinthians 5 7 he knew Christ Our
Passover was slain for us amen I love
how your faith lights up whenever you
talk about the Covenant your face just
starts glowing a pastor dinzi this is
your four minute question in reference
to First John chapter 5 verse 16 can
someone please give an example of a sin
that leads to death this is from
Victoria out of Florida
well thank you Victoria I'm going to go
ahead and read first John chapter 5
verse 16 it says if anyone sees his
brother sinning a sin would just which
does not lead to death he will ask and
he will give him Life For Those who
commit sin not leading to death there is
a sin leading to death I do not say that
he should pray about that I first like
to say about this is that any sin that
you do not confess anything that you do
not give up that you refuse to give up
even the Holy Spirit leading you to
repentance and say you refuse that can
be a sin unto death however it does seem
to indicate here of a specific sin that
leads to death and for this reason I
bring you to Matthew chapter 12 because
here is one where it is identified by
Jesus as something that cannot be
forgiven Matthew Matthew chapter 12 31
and 32 says therefore I say to you every
sin and blasphemy will be forgiven men
but the blasphemy against the holy
spirit will not be forgiven men anyone
who speaks a word against the son of man
it will be forgiven him but whoever
speaks against the Holy Spirit it will
not be forgiven him either in this age
or in the age to come and this is where
we get the term the unpardonable sin so
in this understanding of the
unpardonable sin is that you are
refusing to give up uh
the uh the sin that God is trying to
call you to give up you keep refusing
and refusing and refusing and just like
you're if you're mixing cement uh time
comes that when you're mixing it and you
leave it alone it begins to harden
Harden and it becomes hard as Stone in
the same way the heart that continues to
refuse God's calling God's drawing it
gets harder and harder and the more you
do this the harder it is for you to
respond but God does not give up he
continues and continues until there is
this complete rejection of the holy
spirit in which case you will never
react to the drawing of the Lord and
this becomes the unpardonables and the
sin against the holy spirit so it is a
progressive thing it is not something
that you do at one moment in time it is
something that takes a considerable
process of time and no one can tell you
you have committed the unpardonable sin
this is something that the Lord knows
and it's the time when the Holy Spirit
just has done all that can be done and
you have committed the unpardonable sin
and God sadly has to turn away and
remember that it says in second Peter
chapter 3 verse 9 that God is not
willing that any should perish but that
all should be uh lead led to repentance
and this is a gift of God to lead us to
repentance but if we refuse then God has
to turn away and it becomes the
unpardonable sin in Romans chapter 5
verse 20 there's good news for us it
says moreover the law entered that the
offense might abound but we're sin
abounded Grace abounded much more so
this is talking about a people also they
have the knowledge uh that sin is wrong
they have the understanding that it is
wrong and they continue to persist and
persist in it this then becomes the
unpardonable sin but if you are a sinner
and I've heard of people that have been
gone from the Lord Eve even 20 years and
they're just in a state of just doing
whatever they want to do and the Holy
Spirit does work on them and I'm not
telling you to go out there and do 20
years of sin expecting that you will
repent remember that cement hardens the
more you refuse the more you refuse you
begin to harden your heart so but where
sin abounds Grace much more abounds God
is able to forgive but you must accept
the gift of repentance and proceed to
give it up by the grace of the Lord and
you will find that he is willing to
forgive you amen what a beautiful gift
that is Pastor Wilma King I believe
Jesus will be returning soon and I also
believe there are many pastors preaching
a diluted gospel message concerning
God's Plan of Salvation what are some
Bible verses and a checklist a person
could go through to make sure that they
are truly saved and ready to meet Jesus
this is from Julie out of South Dakota
okay I like the way you put that Julia
checklist you know like Pilots that take
off they know that their destination is
not secure unless they go through a
checklist well let me introduce you to
the checklist it's the whole Bible but
you'll take that and by the Walk of your
life you'll be reading the Bible from
day to day and growing in Grace and in
the knowledge of scriptures but let me
encourage you here very importantly we
find in Ephesians 2 verse 8 and 9
there's no real checklist but the first
thing you have to do is accept salvation
by grace through faith in Christ alone
now I want to make this very clear by
grace through faith in Christ alone not
of works not Grace plus works but grace
alone by grace through faith in Christ
alone the very first thing is accept his
Saving Grace then secondly John 1 verse
12 but as many as receive him to them he
gave the right to become children of God
to those who believe in his name you
follow that acceptance of Christ and
recognize not you are child of God but
you have to continue to believe in his
name why because there's no other name
by which we must be saved thirdly if I'm
putting a checklist together you must
remember you're no longer the person you
used to be second Corinthians 5 and
verse 17 if anyone is in Christ he is a
new creation all things have passed away
don't spend time lamenting the things
that have passed away if if the Lord
gets rid of your sins and wash them away
and says that he cleanse you from all
unrighteousness that now you are
righteous in him don't spend all your
time off I only did didn't do that you
can't reverse what happened just a
second ago don't waste your time on
years of regret when Christ is saying
I've given you a new slate A New
Beginning a new walk in me that means as
Paul says press toward the mob for the
prize of the open call of God in Christ
Jesus
focus in the direction where salvation
comes from and continue growing let the
Lord not only be the author but the
finisher of your faith as Hebrews tells
us and then remember the walk that you
have Romans 8 and verse 1 you have to
walk differently why because the Bible
says there is therefore now no
condemnation to those who are in Christ
Jesus
who do not walk according to the flesh
you can't do the things of the past and
say I'm saved you can't be smoking and
drinking and living you more really and
and living for the world and say well
I'm saved that's all that really matters
there is no such thing it's like saying
I'm married but I'm not really content
in my relationship I want somebody else
well it'll be hard to convince your
spouse that you really are in love with
them
and finally remember this the work that
Christ begins in you he is able to
complete it Philippians 1 verse 6 being
confident I'll say that again be
confident of this very thing that he who
has begun a good work in you will
complete it you know the good news my
brothers and sisters in Christ is
the Lord has committed himself to finish
what he started hallelujah amen and I
believe he can do it amen if anybody
could finish what he started Jesus can
trust his word that's your checklist
amen amen great great great
Shelly how can we explain that Mary the
mother of Jesus was not Divine but human
and needed Jesus as her savior just as
we do this is from Pammy out of Oregon
Tammy I thank you for this quote Pammy
Pammy Pammy thank you for this question
um we stick to the word that's how
in the Bible in the New Testament we see
that Mary is a young virgin betrothed to
Joseph A Carpenter and a betrothal was a
legal marriage contract and it was only
dissolvable by divorce so they were
married in a sense but during the
betrothal period the husband and wife
lived separately from one another not
having intimacy because they were
preparing for marriage but what we find
is Mary was a devout Jew she was she
knew all about God's Everlasting
Covenant she was awaiting the arrival of
the Messiah the deliverer in fact when
she found out that she was praying
treatment and she went to see Elizabeth
her cousin and Zacharias she said in
Luke 1 72 and 73 that God had done this
to perform the mercy promised to our
fathers to remember His Holy Covenant
the oath that he swore to Our Father
Abraham so here's the point Mary's only
mentioned six times with certainty in
scripture possibly another three times
scripture says nothing to venerate Mary
what we find is it presents her as a
virtuous woman it does not present her
as a Perpetual virgin Matthew 1 25 said
Joseph did as the angel had commanded
him he took Mary to him as his wife and
he did not know her that's to consummate
the marriage till she brought forth her
firstborn son and he called his name
Jesus but when we think is she Divine in
Luke 8 verses 19 through 21.
it says
that
Jesus mother and brothers came to him
could not approach him because of the
crowd and it was told him by some who
said your mother and brother
are brothers are standing outside
Desiring to see you
now this is God
Jesus Christ the person the Covenant Son
of God In the Flesh how does he respond
does he say oh I adore her let her come
in no what he says is
he answered them and said my mother and
my brothers
are these who hear the word of God and
do it Jesus did and not venerate Mary
nor does the Bible the six times with
certainty that it's all talking about as
when Jesus was a little child you know
what the last reference to Mary is when
she was with the disciples in the upper
room
at Pentecost and we never hear of her
again
you know I look at some of those
different stories in the Bible and
sometimes I just wish I was a fly on the
wall so I could hear some of those
conversations that's right absolutely
Pastor dinzi after Adam and Eve sinned
they both had to leave Eden was there
another area of Earth outside of the
garden where Satan dwelled or did God
create a separation between Eden and the
rest of the earth after they sinned this
is from dawn
thank you very much Don and this
question here I'm not sure if I am
understanding right it says here was
there another area of Earth outside of
the garden where Satan dwelt or did God
create a separation between Eden and the
rest of the earth yes you can see that
let's go ahead and look at Genesis
chapter 2 verse 8 first and it says and
the Lord God planted a garden Eastward
in Eden and there he put the man whom he
had made first of all Eden was the home
of Adam and Eve God planted this Garden
for them Satan
disguised as a serpent just came to
visit and tent Adam and Eve
but this was not the home of the devil
let's go ahead and see what happens in
Genesis chapter 3 verse 23 and 24 after
Adam and Eve sin this is what took place
therefore the Lord God sent him out of
the Garden of Eden to till the ground
from which he was taken speaking of Adam
so he drove out the man and of course
the woman and he placed cherubim at the
east of the Garden of Eden and a flaming
sword which turned every way to guard
the way to the tree of life so after
Adam and Eve sent their cast out of the
garden and these cherubims were there so
that nobody could come in now the
question is where does the devil and his
angels dwell where do they dwell where
do they live in second Peter chapter 2
verse 4 notice what the Bible says for
if God did not spare the Angels who
sinned but cast them down to Hell and
deliver them into chains of Darkness to
be reserved for judgment so they are
limited to this earth and here is
interesting because it uses the word
hell and it's interesting the word that
is used and it's only used one time in
the Bible and it's really a a word that
is tartaro which the ancient Greeks
considered a place where the dead people
were were
and that according to the Greek
mythology that's where they were also
punished but Peter is writing a letter
and he's writing to people that lived in
what you call a Hellenistic Jewish I
mean Greek setting so he's using
language that that will convey to them
the understanding that Satan and his
angels are in this place of Darkness
because it says they are in Chains of
Darkness he's not adopting this idea of
the Greek mythology he is trying to
teach them that they are confined and
they are reserved for judgment now I see
that my time is running out of this
prison of darkness is the place where
they dwell there's no address that you
can go to over there in the North Pole
they're over there in Rome they're over
there in Washington DC no they're in
Jerusalem God has them limited to a
place this is a spiritual
framing of words to help us understand
that they are limited and they are
confined to this earth in darkness amen
thank you for that explanation
uh Pastor Loma King why does the Bible
say pray he doesn't come on Sabbath or
winter
well when you think about this and thank
you for the question by the way when you
think about this in Jerusalem the winter
would have been brutal the winter would
have been too cold one for Shepherds to
be out in the field that's why we know
Christmas is not the birth of Christ but
the Traditions will make it very clear
that one of the concerns that Jesus had
here
and I find that the two very quick
answers to this one if Jesus intended to
get rid of the Sabbath he wouldn't make
this statement this statement was made
in 31 A.D Jerusalem was destroyed in 30
in 70 A.D so he had 39 years remaining
after this was given by Jesus if his
intention was to destroy the Sabbath or
abrogate the Sabbath or dilute the
Sabbath or
say to the fourth Commandment we no
longer need you I don't want any more
continuations of reminders of me being
Creator there was nothing wrong with the
Sabbath so this was not anything saying
that there was a problem with the
Sabbath but
if it happened in the winter running and
fleeing for their lives would be a
difficult thing as is the case today you
know you've seen this recent tragedy in
Turkey where the 46 000 plus people have
lost their lives but the weather
conditions are tragic in some cases
below zero uh snow had followed this
terrible destruction those are similar
conditions out of which the children of
God would have been facing adverse
circumstances so he said pray that when
this destruction comes it doesn't happen
in the coal region of the Year second
thing pray that it doesn't happen on the
Sabbath why they'll be worshiping on the
Sabbath the quantity of the fellowship
that they enjoy as those who assemble
together forsake not the assembling of
ourselves together I think it's Hebrews
7 25 don't forsake that assembling
together do that and the more so seeing
that the day fast approaches so it's
just a confirmation one that the Sabbath
was not being done away within two God
was concerned about the safety of his
children and when you read about the
historian Josephus said not a single
Christian lost their lives in the
destruction of Jerusalem they followed
plans of the Lord they follow the
prophecies when you see the city
surrounded
don't go back when if you're on the
housetop don't go in the house if you're
in the mountains stay out there and not
a single Christian lost their lives when
Jerusalem was destroyed but just to
reiterate something that you may not be
thinking but just for the benefit of the
topic the Sabbath is mentioned 59 times
in one translation 60 times in the King
James version 57 in the new King James
version and just in the book of Acts is
mentioned eight times
which is a clear indication that there's
nothing wrong with the Sabbath Jesus
didn't come to abrogate it or get rid of
it and is still a sign today of his
creative his creative power to create
the world and his ability to recreate us
as the Sabbath is a sanctifying
influence in our lives amen amen why do
you think so so many times people want
to look in their rear view mirror well
because the bet the past sometimes gets
more attention in the future Lord is
saying like he did the Lot's wife don't
look back the Lord is leading you don't
look back as he said to the children of
Israel I think is in uh Exodus 14 go
forward go forward that's what the
relationship with Christ is all about go
forward press toward that Mark amen if
you're looking in the rearview mirror
while you're going for it chances are
you're going to have an accident
the windshield is bigger
and you definitely don't want to go
through that I can't believe our time is
dwindling this has been such a wonderful
program thus far and I know we're going
to end up having some final thoughts we
definitely want you to know how you can
submit your questions perhaps something
has sparked your interest maybe you you
thought of something that you need to
get answered from the word of God and
you want to send that in we're going to
take a brief break show you how you can
submit those questions and then we will
be right back so don't go anywhere stick
around we'll see you in a minute
if you're enjoying our 3abn Bible q a
then tell your friends each Monday will
bring you a fresh program answering the
Bible questions you send us using God's
holy word to shed light on those texts
that seem difficult to understand to
have your questions answered on a future
program just email them to us at bibleqa
at 3abn.tv that's Bible QA at 3abn.tv
you may also text your questions to
618-228-3975 that's
618-228-3975 be sure to include your
name and where you live and then watch
the Arabian Bible q a for answers from
God's word
I'm so glad that you decided to stick
with us until the end I'm going to open
up the floor for any final thoughts and
we'll start with you Pastor Wilma King
just a quick uh correction I said
Hebrews 7 25 is Hebrews 10 25 forsake
not the assembling of ourselves together
as the manner of some is and so much
more we see the day fast approaching if
there's anything I could encourage you
to do is post covet which there's so
many people that just have not returned
to church let me encourage you go back
the devil wants to use disease to hinder
our fellowship there's nothing as
beautiful as Koinonia in Christ amen
amen amen amen well I like to again talk
to Raymond and really anyone that is
struggling with fleshly lust it says in
Colossians chapter 1 verse 27 to whom
God would make known what is the riches
of the glory of this mystery among the
Gentiles which is Christ in you the hope
of glory the hope of glory for us is to
allow Christ in so that he in us will
make us Victorious amen I just think I
want to add to that is that I mean just
realize how much the lord loves you and
when you realize who he is and what he's
done for you if you will just fall in
love with him it's hard to deny our
flesh and our carnal nature at first but
I guarantee you when you fall in love
with the Lord and start practicing
righteousness Psalm 85 13 says
righteousness goes before him and makes
his footsteps a pathway when you fall in
love with the Lord and you start
practicing righteousness it gets easier
and easier and you want to please him
pray that God will cause you to hunger
and thirst for his righteousness thank
you so much for all of your answers that
you've provided from the word of God we
want to thank you for joining us and for
submitting your questions and just want
to encourage you to study God's word get
to know him fall in love with Christ and
until next time God bless you
[Music]
foreign